Doug O'Neill thoroughbred trainer
two-time Kentucky Derby winner and a
friend of the show and we figured that
we'd check in with Doug and see what his
opinion was his reaction was to what
happened at Churchill Downs Doug good
morning how are you I'm doing great Dan
thanks for having me all right
so you saw the race I'm assuming I did I
did and you know first of all you got a
I want to congratulate all the 19 horses
I've made it to the Kentucky Derby at
such a that's not an easy thing to have
so credit all those great horses and
great horses and to get him there and
yeah that was a crazy race and you know
probably one of the things if you talk
to 50 people 25 would go one way and 25
would go the other you could have went
really either way on it and tough way to
lose the Derby for sure what did you see
would you would you have DQ'd maximum
security right I probably wouldn't have
but because country-house a horse they
moved up wasn't affected by maximum
security but at the same time excellent
security did shift from something and
and took the pass of the number one
horse and I thought Tyler gap Leoni on
him just did an unbelievable job of
staying on and you saw how amazing
athletes these jockeys are and so but
you know I could see where if you're you
know if you're gonna go by the rulebook
I could see where you could take maximum
series number down but it is I was
talking to a couple top jockeys and they
were talking about you know you don't
always officiate a normal NBA game like
you would have Game seven of the NBA
championship and you know you caught
unquote slaughter whistle a little bit I
thought maybe they would let that little
shift go the fact that it didn't really
affect the horse they moved up ahead of
him that's what I wanted to know and I
thought that there was a little bit of
leeway because you have 19 horses and
you have those track conditions Doug
that I mean do I think something
happened yes I do
did it have an impact on who won the
race I don't think it did
and they're therefore given that there's
19 horses and you have those conditions
I I wouldn't have called anything on it
I can't agree and I think that's the
beauty of having a 19 or 20 horse field
is that you know the horse doesn't
always win it's the worst that you know
has the best trip and gets the luckiest
journey around there and watching these
the top riders in the world navigate
these amazing horses around they're in a
big field this is it's awesome and I
agree I really thought they should have
left alone but I can understand why they
did what they did and you know I think
the sewers probably needed maximum
security when they were walking to their
car after the races if you're the
trainer of our owner I should say of
maximum security would you be fighting
this I wouldn't you know I can see I can
see why he wans and his wife are upset
but you know again I think it's easy for
me to say because I've been lucky enough
to have won the Derby and it there is no
crater feeling so but you know I think
he's got some great horses he's a great
owner he'll be there again and you know
you feel for the jacent service barn to
you know what a unbelievable job from
the groom the hot walker the exercise
rider everybody in the barn - he was
definitely the best horse that day and
you feel for them but but is this is
this more the jockey doing what if the
horse just does this or what did you
think the jockey did this I think it was
mainly horse and I'm not sure what he
shied from whether it was the noise of
the crowd or a little you know standing
water somewhere there that kind of
spooked away from a little bit but yeah
I think it was mainly and he was kind of
in control of the race so those horses
that shift a little bit behind him I
thought maybe could have kept their
position if they would have stayed back
a little bit or you know they were kind
of right on his uh they had their horses
head right on his hip a little bit which
you know I would say could be something
they might not have wanted to do in
those conditions but at the end of the
day thank God all the horses and jockeys
came back safe and and you know you just
really feel for him and then credit to
Belmont and his team for what they did
with country house and you know it'll be
interesting as we move forward watching
all these 19 horses where they go from
here would you have wanted to win under
those circumstances oh god I want to win
no matter what you know you wonder what
that winner's circle picture on their
wall is going to look like they're
obviously going to you know delete
maximum security probably they're gonna
do some photoshop in there but you know
I think just the whole build-up and
getting a horse in the Derby is just
such a thrill and you know to have a
horse run second and get DQ'd up you got
to just be you know just so full of joy
and and and excited hopefully he comes
back and runs huge and a Preakness and
it'll really validate the amazing horse
he is now he's not running in the
Preakness the country houses all no
country houses I'm maximum Security's
know I know and I think that is partly I
bet you I think mr. Gary wes is just
probably what sit out a little bit and
not wanting to bring him back over there
in two weeks but I wish you would it
would be great to see those two horses
hook back up for the freakin Assunta
what's the craziest thing you've ever
witnessed
either you know during a race or after a
race at the track well I mean you see
jockeys uh get in fights after the race
that's always entertaining that's a fun
to see so and you know you've seen the
horses coming down the lane head-to-head
and one reach over and fight the other
one it was a doing Lukas had a great
horse named Martha that was known for
bite in this competition so you see some
some wacky things and coming to reminded
me that I think it was 86 37 that bet
twice bumped Alice Sheba a few times
down the lane and Alice Sheba finally
got to the lead in one race or that yeah
or that would have been one that's
might have got DQ'd up at that twice
with a seat in front Ali she busts so
days it's a great race for so many
reasons and yeah I just really feel for
the team service and team with Doug good
to check in with you hope you're well
and we appreciate your time anytime
thanks for having me yeah Dan it's a
Doug O'Neill a two-time Kentucky Derby
winner for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on VR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app